recently a caster by the name of squid
managed to cast a professional game
of cs go with a ridiculous voice
and the worst commentary abilities you
will ever
hear 4-0 would be another baked potato
he somehow got the gig without the
tournament organizers ever actually
hearing or
seeing him beforehand and he made it
through an entire game without being
pulled off air
the craziest part is he sucked on
purpose
it's going to be the most strange thing
you've probably seen today
but he actually did it for a very
serious reason one which he feels
is the biggest threat to csgo casting as
we know it
all right i think this video is gonna
blow your mind but we do have a lot of
videos
like that on this channel so if you
haven't done so already make sure you
are subscribed so you never miss a video
like this one
if you're already subscribed well done
you make great decisions all right so
picture this you've sat down
to watch a tier two european cs go
tournament it's part of a circuit with
2.7
million dollars in prize funds you join
halfway through a best of three
and hope that an expert caster can bring
you up to speed
with all of the action and this is what
you hear
he takes a peek and travis is waiting he
knows he knows he hears
oh boom this is very big yeah
that's not an audio glitch that's not
some fan cast
that is part of the official commentary
for one of the games in this
tournament that is the voice of squid or
rather
his alter ego dom casts aka
the worst csgo caster in the world
since they're not doing a phenomenal job
i wondered how hard it would be to get
onto one of these massive broadcasts
so i decided to enlist the help of a
very
special friend he'll be called domcast
all right you've probably got questions
how did he manage to get on a broadcast
talking like that and perhaps more
importantly
why did he do it well to answer those
questions we first need to talk about
the two companies
that ran this tournament relog media and
grid
talent they're part of the collaboration
who were set to give out a total of 2.7
million dollars in tournament prizes
between 2021 and 2022. each of these cs
go tournaments has prize pools of
hundreds of thousands of dollars with
such fat stacks being thrown around
you'd expect a certain level of
quality from these companies both in
their production
and in the way they treat their talents
but i interviewed squid and according to
him
that just wasn't the case it started in
january when i realized that even though
their prize pulls the prize pools for
their tournaments were going up
um by about it it was going up by two
times three times the amount that they
were actually paying out last year
they were cutting the caster rates they
were bringing solo casting
into their products they weren't
providing any real support their payment
terms like how long they would actually
take to pay a commentator
i think tripled from one month to three
months
now squid had casted for these guys in
the past but felt like
the imbalance between the prize pools
and the caster payments was
kind of reaching a ridiculous level
squid is no rookie to the scene here
he's been a commentator
for over four years now lending his
voice to tournaments run by esl
star ladder and blast to name but a few
to put it simply
he knows what a well-run tournament
should look like
so he wrote a letter to relog media in
january of this year saying that he
wasn't gonna work with him again
until these issues got fixed he got no
reply a while later squid was doing an
investigative piece on kieran cullinan
the talent manager for
grid talent when he and some other
casters who had worked with the company
received this message in a shared
discord
it read for anyone sharing snow sweet
snow payment rates outside of this group
i advise you go and read section 6.1 of
the contract you all signed with us
headed confidentiality data protection
any further news i hear of this will
result in immediate dismissal
for squid threatening to fire casters
for talking about their pay rates
was the final straw he felt something
had to be done
now squid had been signed into grid's
discord under the pseudonym
of dom cass and when he logged in he
found that he actually had access to
all of their protected channels and and
these were all like locked channels that
i would never be allowed
into uh being like kind of like an
outspoken member somebody who speaks
about rates and speaks about this sort
of thing
um like i wouldn't ever be given access
but this dom casts guy
straight access so this fake persona dom
cass
never had any interaction with anyone
from relog media
or grid talon but was now taking part in
conversations that squid himself
wasn't invited to so with the help of
his friend
pronogo squid decided to see just how
far
he could take this would it be possible
to get don cass
a fictional character to cast a
professional game of cs go for these
companies
the aim was that if he pulled this off
it would help expose his theory about
just how
little these companies care about their
production or
talent well squid reached out as domcast
to see if he could cast
the fun spark ulti 2021 qualifier
tournament
for relog media and amazingly he got the
job
he was now gonna cast one best of three
series for them
as a completely fictional character i
cannot stress enough just how absolutely
batshit insane
this whole thing is this job involves
two things
being seen and being heard squid had
somehow managed to get dom cass the gig
without them ever hearing him or seeing
him beforehand
in fact the only thing they'd ever seen
of him was this discord picture
which doesn't exactly ooze
professionalism i mean just look at it
with the gig secured squid spent the
next few weeks preparing he was going to
be on camera for this
so he needed a disguise if they
recognized who he really was they would
undoubtedly just pull him straight off
air
now some people might just slap on a
fake mustache and call it a day but
squid
fully committed to this he decided
domcast was going to be a
bald lithuanian loudmouth who sounded
vaguely like kermit the frog
in squid's video on all of this he shows
himself working with a vocal coach
and a lithuanian caster to try and learn
some convincing phrases to use on the
day
going to the dwarves going to the toilet
basically same thing
something exciting something amazing is
when your eyeballs pop out of your
forehead
roof drives away it's when um
when things are crazy as for the
appearance squid spent
three hours in a makeup chair to
transform himself
into dom cass and finished off the
outfit with a baggy suit and an
oversized lumberjack jacket which
actually used to belong to his
great-grandad when the big day came
squid told me he actually felt pretty
nervous so i had spent two months
editing this video
and making the scenes and writing and
everything if i got yanked off
five minutes into the broadcast there is
no video there's nothing
uh the project's done i look like an
idiot
instead of somebody who pulled this off
basically the difference between being
an idiot and
coming up with a really smart idea is so
thin
in this field where if it goes wrong i
just look like a [ __ ]
like i look mental the nerves were
definitely kicking in
but dom cass had his bald cap he had his
jacket
and he had his lithuanian phrases it was
show time
what you're about to see is the first
time anyone from the outside world had
ever
seen or heard dom cass including the
people
that hired him hello and welcome to the
fun sparks everybody's
we have very exciting game today with
one win and 100 pin
guards he'd made it past the first
hurdle with no one from relog media
pulling the plug
as he got into the game he turned things
up a notch by putting on perhaps
the worst casting performance you will
ever hear in your life it's not there
anymore not there at all
not there one bit
not there to take the hit
they play this is a very messy game
it was beautifully insane squid told me
that the hardest part of all of this was
that after casting for four years
professionally
he had to re-learn how to be a bad
caster
we did some practice sessions before we
got into this
and during the practice sessions all of
the feedback
basically all of the feedback was this
guy's too good he knows too much about
the game
he's reacting too quickly to the kills
basically what you need to do is just
look at the kill feed at the top right
and just read that pretend that
nothing's happening in the game
and that was the advice that was given
to me so that's what i
did because that's what the the world's
newest caster probably would do
and that's exactly what he did he just
started listing
the names of players one by one suddenly
they all clicked into place and deco
and the scout and sorrow
and smiley and smiley and deco
and sorrow let's look at one last clip
because
why not i love them and i want you guys
to remember that this is being streamed
to thousands of people who don't know
what's going on
and maybe an ace is it an ace to finish
no pulp steals it
boom other than a couple of audio issues
nobody from relog media had
any problem with domcast's ridiculous
performance
it was a long best of three and at times
squid did struggle to keep the
ridiculous voice of dom cass going i
mean you tried talking like kermit the
frog
for three hours but eventually he got
over the finish line
so we had four best of three today
we have more best of three next week
we will see you next time naturally
it was now time for domcass to get paid
for all his hard work
they paid um after
about 45 minutes of the video being live
which was basically i saw that is the
best
middle finger ever it was funny it was
classy
um but obviously their casters
usually wait three months to get paid
after the events
so it's also it's also ironic in that
sense that i got paid immediately it's
okay right let's get this guy out of our
hair
and let's not give him something else to
fight back with because uh yeah the
original
concept was to make a follow-up video
try to get don
paid we can't make that anymore and how
much did he get paid for this gig
i hear you ask about 50 euros or 60 u.s
dollars
and in squid's video he points out that
this is kind of peanuts compared to the
money that's involved with this kind of
production
gritty sports cs go circuit prize pool
in 2021
looks like this that is 2.7
million dollars whereas the average
gritty sports cast a paycheck
looks like this it's a pathetic 20 euros
squid was pleased to see a lot of
support coming from the community
the buzz on social media was
overwhelmingly positive
sadly the relog representative he was in
contact with didn't quite agree with
that feedback and shut down any notion
of doncast making a return to the
tournament
anytime soon when the mask and costume
finally came off
which looked like something out of a
horror movie squid hoped that those who
found his stun
funny also took away his stark warning
about the state of csgo
casting i feel like we've got a lot of
organizations in esports right now who
do not care about
integrity whatsoever a commentator is
supposed to be the face of your brand
the face of your product and if you
don't care about who that person is and
whether they have integrity themselves
then how are you supposed how does that
reflect badly on your product for squid
this whole thing is a bit of a
trickle-down situation he believes that
if these companies don't have integrity
with their production and pay their
casters fairly and promptly
then the whole system can start to erode
from the top down he believes that if
casters lose their own integrity and
belief as a result
that they're not able to do their job
properly and engage with the viewers
with fresh content and captivating story
lines
so what's the solution here well that
may be beyond the scope of this video
but squid had suggested that some sort
of external regulation
might work a body that keeps these
companies in check and holds them
to certain ethical standards before the
bubble bursts the overwhelming feeling i
got when talking to squid was one of
passion he didn't just do this stunt for
a laugh or retweet
he did it because he really cares about
the scene and especially his fellow
casters
one of the questions that a lot of
people seem to have about dom cass
after watching this stunt is when is his
next video well although squid hasn't
confirmed the character's return
just yet he did tell me that he has
other characters and similar stunts
lined up
in the future so let's hope these videos
continue to shine a light on the darker
corners of cs go
and in the meantime we've still got one
hell of a video to share with friends
and with iceman finding another one he
is ice cold
and so is winter they are both a cold
brothers i'd like to see if i could get
a job
as a north american caster he's going to
be site i think he's going to be able to
start the bomb oh he's picked up the gun
he's picked up the op
he's picked up the orp and then people
and then people go what what do you say
oh they are you picked up the app
i said the app it's it's right sorry
this car
was coffee